hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley baby
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is ru garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians
and find out if they grow up classy or
if they're a complete piece of [ __ ]
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a glorious day here at gas digital
studios
in the [ __ ] east village it's nice
and cool
i can feel the fall coming i can taste
the [ __ ] turkey on thanksgiving
and i'm excited my co-host coming at you
right next to me a little too close if
it was any closer i'd be [ __ ]
pregnant
this guy gang the next time you reach it
for a best pal you go ahead and make it
a kippy
give it the [ __ ] up for mr kevin james
ryan everybody
hey what's up everybody thanks so much
for tuning in as always we appreciate
you listening the show
watching you can uh make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes
and also full video is available on
youtube you can subscribe there as well
and you can use promo code ayg to sign
up for gas digital network to get all
the shows on the network and a bunch of
cool [ __ ] as well
yes sir thank you kippy and gang we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest
here with us today via satellite
technology
he's a huge get we got him on the big
screen gang this gentleman is a comedian
a podcaster and actor and producer
you have seen him on this is not
happening the late late show the joe
rogan experience bachelor
and of course he is the host of honeydew
podcast
but the big question everybody's wearing
today is he garbage
and i don't know he looks like a
detective that got caught up with the
bad people
ladies and gentlemen give it up for the
one the only mr ryan sickler
thank you guys buddy thank you so much
for doing the show man we're happy to
have you here
thank you for having me i'm it's a
pleasure to be here and i can tell by
i can tell you right now i know the
answer because the [ __ ] you got on the
shelf behind you that's
ten times more than we had in our fridge
and cabinets
we just bought this at the bodega about
an hour ago by the way and it better be
here next week i'll tell you that
you do look like a detective that would
be on the take right now i can say that
if i was a detective i would you could
definitely put me on it
oh i would turn the blind eye to a lot
of [ __ ]
keep the neighborhood safe that's about
as far as i would go
um but yeah thank you so much for doing
the show so like i said what we're going
to do is we're going to ask you a series
of questions to determine whether you're
a garbage or not
but before we get into that i'm just
curious where'd you grow up how'd you go
up give us the whole uh
give us the whole origin story the
backstory
my origin story i'm originally from
baltimore
uh um that's a tough one he looks like
he's on the [ __ ] right now
i'm here in the studio in this damn
sideways cam here we go
um grew up in ball i'm from baltimore
originally
uh parents divorced bounced around
grew up out in um in the county carroll
county maryland
split homes uh mostly by raised by a
single dad
uh who worked we were latch key kids i
say we i have a twin brother
fraternal twin brother and a younger
brother um
so you know three boys basically being
raised by a single dad mom's not really
around
in and out running around a little bit
um
they divorce it's like summer of fifth
between fifth and sixth grade
we live with my mom for a year they
decide to get back together
um you know that for the kids [ __ ]
yeah that always works
yeah we're not gonna need any questions
i'll tell you that
i like how i like how he referred to it
as the county too like we knew
like i knew what [ __ ] county he was
talking yeah down there in the county
you guys know [ __ ] the county there's
one county i love it
when you're when you're god damn it
when you're look see i'm sorry when
you're from baltimore you're either from
the city or you they all they ask
you from the county
so single dad um and then when i'm 16 my
father dies of a heart
attack we find him dead in the morning
um we our mom still is like
nah his mom our grandmother
comes to take care of us for a little
bit um and then at that point
the state were minors so we had to go
somewhere and we end up moving in with
our mother
who left us alone um just we raised
ourselves from
16 all the way through school my my twin
brother myself
um and um yeah once we turned 18 my mom
kicked us out she was never home
or around jesus yeah so we moved in with
my grandmom the same grandmom who was
just
awesome i mean just a [ __ ] awesome
woman
she dropped out of a heart attack right
in front of me at
night i gave her mouth-to-mouth and cpr
and i did a good job she was alive when
she left the house but did not me wow
holy [ __ ] that's why on my instagram bio
i'm three for four saving lives
holy [ __ ] he's got his record on the
gram hey those are all star numbers i
don't don't feel bad
hall of fame that's good holy [ __ ]
you're like [ __ ] superman in my book
i was gonna lead off to see if you ever
had lunchables growing up you hit us
with [ __ ]
the shameless rewrites holy [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] tale first of all i'm
sorry that happened to you
thanks man oh after [ __ ] oh i
we had an uncle who came in and
basically was like
man [ __ ] everybody we were thrown out
um i lived with my grandmom's sister my
aunt marguerite for a little bit
until we found our own place i say we my
my twin brother and i got a place for a
year
and then after that i moved out here and
i've been here ever since
so that's my nutshell story right there
for you what happened to the twin
brother
uh he currently um lives in delaware
with his wife and my niece and nephew he
um
he manages an auto salvage company so
he's in charge of all the aluminum
recycling all that get a headlight if
you need one for sure
buddy get this down into a treatment i
like it
they do crazy [ __ ] like you know those
you see those tractor trailers go down
the road with the the cars
all squished down he does that then
they'll take those cars they'll bring it
to his place they melt them down
into these aluminum pallets and then
they sell the aluminum
for profit um and then it basically goes
overseas and they make big
razors out of and it comes right back we
paid 40
and [ __ ] razors they used to be a
buick skylar
the classiest of the buick by the way
something in a four-door
please not garbage he is a scientist
for the government he works he's not in
the army but he works
for the army in maryland he's married
with three kids
actually now let me ask you this because
first of all i would never have had i
was raised you know i was babied my
entire life i would never have had
the wherewithal to overcome [ __ ] like
that which is [ __ ]
amazing and commendable to all three of
yous especially with all three as you're
successful in doing good
but does something like that experience
like would you say that you guys
are super close now and try to create a
really strong
family environment for like your nieces
and your nephews
or are you guys kind of scattered well
a little bit of both honestly we're we
are my brothers and i are very close we
talk
all the time um and you know
any of the kids moms will probably tell
you we're a little harder on the kids
but it's also because we know that at
any [ __ ] second that [ __ ] could be
ripped away from you and you
better [ __ ] step up and be somebody
and not just
a stick not just the [ __ ] you know
loser not just the glom on so my
my twin brother started before all of us
did um
so my niece and nephew are now got i
think 13 and 11.
my younger brother my daughters will
turn six in october my younger brother's
kids are
seven five and he's got a
one and a half year old so those kids
are much closer in age
uh but yeah we we you know i'm still
friends with my cousins who were
10 15 years older than me so it's harder
to do that when i'm out here
because i'm in california they're still
in and my one brother's in delaware and
the others in maryland so
it's close but they they need to be
closer that's
that's a really good question they
should be closer okay because i figured
something like that either
you're gonna go two different ways from
it you're gonna recognize the importance
of family and having like a support
system
and and go that route or you just don't
really talk to each other at all
that's good that you guys still held on
through all that
i mean we were literally laying there on
the bed together with our dad's dead
body and my brother and i are i'm
breathing life into my [ __ ] ground i
mean i never in my and i had just
just gotten to be a lifeguard i just
took all these [ __ ]
cpr classes and [ __ ] here i am having to
[ __ ] use it on my grandmother i've
never used that [ __ ] on any [ __ ]
you sleep in the shallow end you're on
your own yeah diving for rings i ain't
coming in to get you shouldn't have been
diving
i'm not messing up my hair to dive in
for you i'll tell you that
so when when was it completely
and what kind of shock is that like when
you're a kid when like your mom splits
like that like when was it normal
up until you said fifth sixth grade
no it was a little before that i'd say
normal what you would say no
it's never been normal like my mom's mom
my
she lived with us early on too and now
you look back and it's like oh we had a
really nice house
um and she lived there to help pay for
that [ __ ] house you know what i mean
so we always had
something different going on but normal
i'd say right around
third grade is when when they started
having
for for me you know that age they
started having trouble when you started
i remember
in in students in third grade in my
class
hey are your parents divorced because i
we felt like these outcasts but then
then you realize [ __ ] the people whose
parents were together were
were the ones that were in the smaller
uh
statistical group yeah and sometimes
when they stay together
yeah yeah yeah that stay together for
the kids [ __ ] don't always work
yeah uncle hank's a product of that i'll
tell you i would have been gone
that's [ __ ] crazy i'll say this
though it is garbage to have
uh like a grandmom or an aunt or
something like that live with you but
when you're a little kid
that's so cozy because they [ __ ] you
know they don't on yeah
it's like a clubhouse you know what i
mean there's just a bunch of people
hanging around you know it's like more
people to do [ __ ] with more people to
take care of or make dinner and [ __ ]
i love that [ __ ] my whole family's
italian so my grandmother
spoke italian fluently in the home to
her sisters
and to this day i'm bummed i didn't sit
and learn
that [ __ ] language because i know she
was talking [ __ ] about everybody
oh yeah dude she was probably holding
court openly
talk [ __ ] about what was going on and
not have to hide or leave or go anywhere
yeah i wish i spoke a second language
just to trash people
something odd too like korean or
something like that just being a green
room [ __ ] [ __ ] on the guy next to you
nothing better what did you pick up from
your grandmom how's your uh
how's your sunday gravy at the sickler
house um
well i picked up so that was my mom's
mom that lived with us earlier i was
much much closer with my dad's mom who
later i lived with and
tried to say um but what i got from all
of them
was what you asked me about before like
i you know these people literally died
for us and there was no way i was going
to let
their life be wasted or
you know be that drug addict or
alcoholic or
dead i mean i should be i should be dead
in the ditch i should have been
long i'm amazed but
all three of us you know it was more
about
you know living out the way our father
and grandmother
had instilled in us and what ultimately
ends up happening i've reconnected with
my mother and i've talked to her about
this i'm like we made you look good you
know what i mean you didn't have
[ __ ] to do with that but we did what we
were supposed to do for the people
uh we wanted to do it for and ultimately
we ended up making you look like a
really good parent and you weren't
you know wow so what i got was integrity
i got
heart i got hustle you know don't be
allergic to hard work
but what i did modify was taking a blue
collar work ethic and applying it to a
white collar world
yeah for sure and not just keeping that
in the blue collar world
there's something about that blue
because same thing both of our families
blue collar yeah
construction and stuff like that it's
like when that's instilled in you in a
lo at a young age there's just something
you especially when the family unites
like that with that blue collar work
it's like put your head down and just
[ __ ] go it's got to get done it's
going to get done tight mentality of
like you have no other choice
it's either like you said like just let
go and become a statistic or [ __ ]
push through until you know
the next level and the fact that not
only did you push to the next level the
fact that you're [ __ ] killing it
i know it's you know it's [ __ ]
awesome
i don't always feel like i'm killing it
but that's nice you to say you should be
coaching
wrestling or something
[Laughter]
hot gym coach i want to be here i mean
that was a powerful [ __ ] speech i was
trying to get up and start doing some
burpees on that
i was [ __ ] [ __ ] coach sickler
coming in
the [ __ ] streets of hard knocks yeah
i
my father was a crew chief at pan am and
his father
worked at bethlehem steel in baltimore
so they're blue guys
and you know they uh both were in the
military
i was not you know what i mean like i'm
not the man
[ __ ] were at all so the least i can
do
and it's been actually pretty [ __ ]
awesome to sit here and
on my own show and and shows like yours
and to sit here and talk about these
people that meant the world to me
because it's the
only way to keep them alive you know
they they would
love to [ __ ] know i was talking about
their ass on these shows believe me my
grandmother
what you say about me this week you know
[Laughter]
that's funny you know i definitely know
i am a
i am a much watered down version of my
father i can tell you that
oh yeah i don't even [ __ ] i'm barely
a man i'll be honest with you
we're sitting there sitting here talking
to the microphones about real men that's
what we're doing
yeah but that's good all right we got
that's a [ __ ] amazing
backstory so that just kind of gives us
an idea how to kind of like tailor the
questions specifically to you
um i'm interested in a couple of uh
things about when you're when when you
were living with your dad like how he
made it all work
but now i i'm more intrigued about
how you run your house yeah and like and
like what your habits are
now so we're gonna launch into a series
of questions here we're gonna play a
little game called
are you garbage uh just answer the
questions as openly as honestly as you
have been
which is [ __ ] fantastic i'll tell you
what i don't know if you're garbage or
not but i [ __ ] love you yeah i'll be
rooting for you in the movies
[ __ ] remake rudy and put the kid in
i'm [ __ ] hooked
i'm about
yeah i saw that today he he said was he
carried out on
people's shoulders yeah by three of the
pranksters on the team
yeah he just [ __ ] all over he's like
dude he popped that rudy bubble
if you yeah he took all the hollywood
out of that [ __ ] movie real quick
sure
he should get all over that he's a notre
dame guy too i believe he was on the
team right there yeah
yeah he was that's what he was saying he
goes that's all [ __ ] they put him in
for 10 seconds he
well like oh he was on that [ __ ] team
oh i didn't know that that's what he's
saying i mean that's the thing he's
going i was there it was all [ __ ]
yeah and i banged his girl afterwards
[ __ ] him
like joe montana's gotta take this win
what the [ __ ] joe relax
come on joe put your sketchers on
[Laughter]
more of a dan marino man myself i'll
tell you what para isa toners are on the
holidays
holy [ __ ] also too obviously you're free
you know you're about your background's
a little checkered you know what i mean
it wasn't all [ __ ] you didn't grow up as
like a rockefeller you know what i mean
yeah that's not going to determine
whether you're garbage or not but you
have those
roots like you were definitely you know
you were you so you have garbage roots
and we found out
regardless of money of fame of
you know success there's only so much
one generation can do to shake the
garbage out you know what i mean like
your kids are going to be a little bit
better but they're going to still have
tendencies so it's it's
it's it's interesting to see how what
you've been able to shake maybe he got
even more trash here with a little bit
of cash your ricky bobby did who knows
okay let's see all right let's
are you married are you are you married
now
i am not i was engaged originally we
broke it up well she broke it off
and i have a five-year-old daughter i've
been a single dad for the last
well she's about to be sick so last five
years your daughter lives with you
we have 50 50 split custody i will not
[ __ ]
i'm yeah there's no way of course i got
it
okay all right um how do you want to
start this off what are you thinking
i think we still got to go with the with
the basics growing up let's go back
before
uh before there was trouble um
just to get an idea what was the name of
the street that you grew up on i know
you moved around a lot
but the first first street the house
that i told you about that
that i'm not going to include the city
i'll include when we got out to the
county because that's counter baby
yeah that's where we planted the flat
state out there
um but that would be iron gate iron gate
circle actually it was a cul-de-sac man
no that's what that's what i didn't know
this either it was a a loop it was a
he called them we called them courts
where i came from in maryland if you
cul-de-sac was a court go but play into
court play in the court
but a circle which i'd never even known
either was just like a horseshoe and it
went from one side to the other side and
they called it iron gate circle
that sounds pretty close that's pretty
classy man iron gate that just bumped up
the story
bartholo corner of iron gate and
bartholo
that was the corner that's pretty that
sounds pretty ritzy sounds pretty nice
man
um it all went downhill from there oh
man those are the days though
now that picture you guys fighting over
your dad's estate and [ __ ] like that
i was my that was my pipe wrench
[ __ ]
um what uh what kind of house are we
talking was it like a single-family
duplex apartment
no this was a house that's why it was my
favorite this was before
[ __ ] hit the fan and we ended up in the
apartments and all that [ __ ] this was a
split level um you walked in you could
go upstairs to like a nice
um see i don't know house is enough but
it was a whole
like parlor area with the kitchen
walk-through dining room
up another level to one two three
bedrooms yeah
one of those had a full bath there was
another full bath in the hallway
when when you walk in to the right was
my parents master bedroom
downstairs excuse me again to a basement
and then
ahead was the whole living room huge
yard like
like riding mower yard garden [ __ ]
built all that like you know you gotta
you gotta have a taste of it for a
little bit
before you realize how you know shitty
it's about to get yeah
that sounds like a good slice of america
right there it does
the other thing the only thing working
against you on that they got the yard
stuff like that
but i i'm hearing too many levels this
is like an mcs sure painting
and like the the kitchen on the second
floor
yeah that's a tough one right there
that's a little garbagio my friend and
the master bedroom on the first floor
basement was not done
basketball court in the driveway like
right in the driveway you had to move
cars to play ah that's the best did you
have a chain net or was it
was it a mesh net that was a mess it was
all right
you start to change that's [ __ ]
street ball time dude
those were those were at all the
playgrounds because everyone kept taking
the [ __ ] yeah
yeah they had to bolt them down yeah
dude my mom still to this day i think i
mentioned one here before still has a
chain net in our [ __ ] driveway
it's like [ __ ] rucker park in there
yeah it's wild there's nothing worse
than playing a pickup game with no
[ __ ] net you feel like you're in the
prison yard man yeah
russ rattling off every time yeah
swish sounds terrible yeah it sounds
like two knights fighting in medieval
times
sounds like someone's getting stabbed at
lunch
holy [ __ ] all right okay and what about
another basic here
all right so we got the street what was
the name of the grocery store that let's
say
your dad went to why he was trying to
keep it all together
after your mom was gone that would have
been george's
that sounds pretty nice i don't know it
how was your pop in the kitchen
my dad you know what i've always found
especially about military dads is they
kill breakfast i don't know what it is
yeah
they're all maybe they were up early i
don't know what it is but i
if if my friends asked me to spend the
night
i would always ask was your dad in the
military
[Laughter]
yeah give me your dad's rank before i
commit i want to know what he was
dude this guy breaks my balls at a time
my dad was in the [ __ ] navy
he was a cook in the navy and exactly
what you're talking about my mom can
make every meal
every night of the week but come sunday
morning the big guy was behind two cast
iron skillets
[ __ ] frying up some canned potatoes
and some [ __ ] dippy eggs
and they were out of the park fantastic
my dad was a good cook steaks burgers
and we all you know we're maryland
through and through so we would steam
crabs and seafood
all the [ __ ] time like that is
something i
that's all over my ig i still do that i
mean it's
i can't i just love i love look i
am a backyard crab feast barbecue
[ __ ] hang out horseshoes beer and
weed guy
that is who i am newspapers out on the
table dump a bushel out everybody's got
a screaming cold coors light
[ __ ] good night
out there with the kids playing some
kickball kicking the [ __ ] out of that
thing
going yard coach zickler goes yard again
i'd rather that than to go to any
premier party or any of these [ __ ]
red carpets i've ever done i'd much
rather that that is who i
am i also imagine you probably don't
take it easy on the kids and like let
them win when you're in a [ __ ]
showing them how to play horseshoes for
20 bucks a throw
they already have it better than i'll
ever had it
[Laughter]
ungrateful bastards i love that you're
coming up [ __ ] all class with me
right now i'll tell you that all right
even with the horseshoes
yeah a horseshoe pit in the backyard is
fun but it's trash
if you're taking the refund check and
putting in a horseshoe pit you should be
making some better investments
oh when you were a little kid the first
time you saw adults throwing horseshoes
and being like serious
about it you like hearing that clank
like what the [ __ ]
yeah couple of michelobs going around
man that's a [ __ ]
man's game right there i got one along
that line does anyone in your family or
you ever own your own tap for a keg
yeah i had an uncle that had a kegerator
nice
yeah that's nice dude yeah
yeah that's clean living let's ask you
this this is a big one here
uh on are you garbage now if you didn't
have one you're still high up in the
point so don't worry
but at the house in the circle did you
guys have a garage
no no garage i'm trying to think
we lived in a shitload of houses and i'm
trying to think
i don't know if any of the ones we had
maybe when we lived in texas for a hot
second we had a garage we went down
there for like a year or my dad got
transferred but we were there for
nothing but no
and this is gonna this is not gonna help
my points any it was a it was just an
outside driveway but
but i've had multiple gravel driveways
the best when you tear
out on one of them and your parents are
freaking out oh
dude those are a tough look let me ask
you this would they get it re-graveled
every couple of years and they'd show up
with a dump truck and you'd have to
smooth it out
my buddy's dad every couple of years he
would get fresh gravel put in
and he'd have us out there on a [ __ ]
saturday raking it like we were on a
[ __ ] chain
gang smoothing it out so what i was
trying to find out is anywhere in any of
these houses
was there a second refrigerator maybe in
the basement or in the house that was
strictly
for sodas beer and ice pops
yes and no actually so i guess there was
uh we had a deep freeze in the house
that my father
died in okay we had a deep freeze and
in here we go this will help your points
oh god so we put your dad for a couple
of days
we used to go crabbing all the time we
had a little uh
john boat we go out into the y river off
the chesapeake and we'd run
trot lines and the bait would be bull
lips
you go to a butcher you get the lips
from bowls you
you put them on every three feet uh
yards excuse me
and boom we're crabbing okay well you
don't throw
100 yards of bull lips away because you
can use that all summer so what you do
is you coil it into a bushel basket
then you take that stank ass trot line
and you put that in the deep freeze so
we would keep our trot line in the deep
freeze
any venison you know my dad hunted
actually when we got older he didn't but
he still had friends so we'd have some
deer meat
um things like that so not soda and and
freezy pops and [ __ ] like that we had
man [ __ ] yeah that's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
believe me i got the message
i stink fair i'm looking for a capri
sun you got [ __ ] gopher ass in there
that's [ __ ]
that's a man right there i've never
heard anybody talk about buying bull
lips oh [ __ ]
yeah i kind of wish he was here because
he could smack our heads together i know
clunk has like two coconuts
i ain't never had no [ __ ] high c
cooler fat boy i'll tell you that
oh man we got one we got one we got a
deep freeze cooler too
and uh we might my step dad keeps
baiting there for crabbing and [ __ ] like
bunker and [ __ ] like that
so any meat or chicken and whenever you
start cooking it smells like you're at a
[ __ ] bait shop i'm like i ain't
eating this
i'll go to mcdonald's before i eat this
bunker steak
how about throwing a french bread pizza
in there to [ __ ] i know
bring up the real estate a little bit
yeah those deep freezers
they don't they don't do good with
smells that that [ __ ] bleeds
and let me follow that up with this
because that's such a staple
and you seem like such a man's man
growing up
would you have milk with dinner
no yeah thank you mr sickler the
gentleman
jesus might be turning
much of soda because my father again he
worked at the airport he'd come home
with a garbage bag of
[ __ ] braille coca-cola sprite we
drank
way too much soda growing up way too
much what taking it from the airplanes
but whether the little little baby cans
the little mini ones
we get some of those too but you asked
me about the either now you remind him
so we never put that [ __ ] in the freezer
we just kept that in trash bags in the
basement and we would just put ice in a
glass and drink
drink a soda it's in the tiny little cup
we have
dead animal parts in our
[Laughter]
we got no room for shasta in there i'll
tell you that
exactly god damn this guy's from is this
common knowledge this is a crazy [ __ ]
story man
i love this it's my story
it feels normal when you're living it at
first i'll tell you
you don't realize how different it is to
go over to your friend's house you're
like
hey you guys get hugs
oh ain't that the [ __ ] truth okay
damn um i feel like i might i might get
you with
anybody do you know anybody that ever
played semi-pro football
yeah yeah you're talking to one that's a
[ __ ] tight end
actually it's actually professional
football
so well i'm friends i'm friends now with
orlando brown jr from the ravens the
right tackle
oh damn okay on the greatest rushing
uh team in the history of the sport but
also i went to high school with a guy
i'm still friends with him his name is
mark orlando shout out to mark orlando
he was a wide receiver
so long story short baltimore loses the
colts
um and we get we get a usfl
team called the baltimore stars right
well the colts have
championships this is why baltimore is
the greatest
football city in the history of football
he's saying that
it's not even close for debate this is
fact
and when i go through this very quickly
you will be like you're right okay we
had the baltimore colts
who predated super bowls they won nfl
championships they also won
super bowls okay super bowl they went to
super bowls
johnny united right exactly
then also actually and then 1970
um they won so then they leave town we
get the baltimore stars
a usfl team they win the championship
they leave town we get a canadian
football
team called the baltimore stallions and
to date the baltimore stallions
are the only us team to ever win
the grey cup championship they leave
town
we get the ravens who have won two super
bowls
every [ __ ] team in football that we
have had come to our city
has dominated and been to the
mountaintop period
there are not there's not another city
that's ever had a canadian team
who's won a championship so
automatically
baltimore in every [ __ ]
version of football yeah has hit the
mountaintop and it's why it's the
greatest football city now mark orlando
wasn't semi-pro he was actually a pro
and he was a receiver for the stallions
who won
he was on the team that won the great
cup
damn that's pretty flawless [ __ ] i
got you can't even know that i don't
even know anybody could rebut that at
all i can't
argue with that i just feel bad
everybody keeps leaving town on you your
[ __ ] mom
[ __ ] football teams can't get anybody
to stay and give this guy a [ __ ]
hug jesus christ lamar jackson better
not [ __ ] move anywhere
god forbid if something happens to that
kid oh i love him i'll be honest with
you he's a [ __ ] good kid right there
i'll tell you that man it should have
someone like that on your team
because i love i love football so i'm a
big fan of a lot of guys but to have one
like that on your team where you're like
[ __ ] yes yeah and he's a [ __ ] good
dude
he is yes all right holy [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] tail we are spinning here
what was your first car
because you were out on your own pretty
quick
first car i paid 500 for it was a 1982
toyota corolla tercel
people argue with me that there wasn't a
corolla and after herself there was
i've had to prove it online there
[ __ ] was
it was blue it was matte paint it didn't
even have a finish i bought it off my
high school soccer coach's son and
what i didn't know the fuel filter had a
hole in it
and my buddy and i drove it all the way
to the beach and this thing's
spitting gas right into the vent we were
so [ __ ] tired when we got there
everybody's like wow we're gonna take a
nap
we used to jump that [ __ ] on on roads
that have big hills we'd all get out and
jump our cars
holy [ __ ] that reminds me
you don't see this too much but asking
somebody for a jump
do you have do you remember having to do
that [ __ ] i don't think anybody would do
it for you now who the [ __ ] somebody
asked me for a jump i'd like to
get your [ __ ] together yeah you're not
[ __ ] putting that on my car
no blow my [ __ ] out yeah
you don't know how to treat your car
you're not touching mine how many miles
were on that toyota
in the end do you remember i don't
remember on that one but my favorite car
which was my second car was a 1990 honda
civic with original rims and i put 275
280 000 on that car god damn
that's [ __ ] something else yeah those
foreign cars in the 80s and 90s you'd
put like [ __ ] 2 million miles on them
and then [ __ ] sell it to a high
school kid they ran forever yeah
it's a lawnmower yeah gang we know
everybody's going through a tough time
right now but i'll tell you what we've
got the cure and of course we're talking
about
dick at your door.com gang
holy cow folks let's face it everyone's
bummed out right now
so why not send your loved ones or your
enemies
some delicious chocolate dicks oh yeah
that's the ultimate face though right
there check out what i'm working with
mine would be a morsel but that's
neither here nor there
i mean gang who knows this might be the
one thing that'll keep your grandma
alive
or kill her 100
handcrafted chocolate in the shape of
dicks
what more do you want you can send them
anonymously or grow some balls and put
your name on it
they also make prank greeting cards that
make [ __ ] noises when you open them
nice little squeaky squeaky when you
open a car huh put a c note in there and
a little bit of [ __ ]
so check out dickatyourdoor.com and if
you use the promo code garbage
you'll save 15 on possibly the most
delicious chocolate dick
you'll ever have in your mouth
unfortunately
we can't say the same about nana you
know what i mean yeah
gang once again that's
tickingyourdoor.com and use promo code
garbage
to save 15 now back to the show kippy
okay have you ever saved
let's see here actually any of your
family members ever owned a pontoon boat
wait say it again any of your family
members ever own a pontoon boat
oh own one no no [ __ ] partied on one
hell yes
i've definitely partied on pontoon dude
nothing's better than a couple of cold
30 packs and a pontoon boat and high
tide
good night take that thing out in open
waters try to cross the channel with it
it's by far the trashiest boat the
funnest but the trashiest because it's
just for people you can't fish
you can't like water ski on it it's just
for people getting [ __ ] up in the bay
and it's
awesome in the shade yeah shade yeah
some of them even have toilets on them
like the pop-up
uh you like [ __ ] in a bucket my brother
when i first moved to california
he thought it'd be a good idea to buy
this shitty rv i mean it was a shitty rv
he was so stoked to drive me across
country and we're going to put an extra
battery in it and play playstation i was
like this thing ain't going to
run make it out of the county dawg
playstation
it didn't it never went anywhere
oh that's [ __ ] uh i love the dream
though i'm gonna get this we're gonna
get a [ __ ] playstation
and cruise you gotta love the dreamer
mentality
that's so funny we're getting that's
like a springsteen song we're getting
out baby
get this rv get this camper pop and go
on a personal note we've been going over
uh this has been a big controversy this
week on twitter
how do you feel because i want to know
what like what
all this is done to you and like what
your habits are like now
do you feel it's garbage to brush your
teeth in the shower
no no i don't
i listen i don't here's when i i do it
once in a while
and it's if i'm doing it in the morning
when i wake up if i'm gonna
about me i like succeed shower at night
i don't like to get up and shower in the
morning i shower before i go to bed i
get up
and then i'll wash my face and stuff
like that unless i sweat real bad
tonight i don't shower in the morning
but when i do i brush my teeth in the
shower because i like to multitask i
like to get [ __ ] done
there you go spoken like a gentleman
that [ __ ] ends that debate right now
oh it's still crushing your teeth in the
shower is good
no i would do it all the time it's too
dirty for me i mean there's people you
know who knows what's going on in the
shower people are washing their ass
people are peeing it's all seen in there
right
are you laying down and brushing your
teeth
i'm a big bath kind of guy i don't know
if you're brushing your teeth in the
bath
now that's a [ __ ] another story right
there running it under the faucet while
you're filling it up
shaving your legs
all right one i got one now let's see
let's see you know
is there currently a purple crown royal
bag in your home today
no no no crown royals okay the big the
thing about people saving those bags is
that's a real garbage move
people think that's fancy so they're
like i can't throw this out i got to put
some
coins or golf tees in here or something
yeah some dominoes
what about a tv tray is there a set of
tv trays in your house right now
no tv trays no but i'll be honest with
you i'd love to have it
if you guys know a guy that delivers
that to l.a hook me up
where do you normally eat your eat your
meals well you will you
when you like say when you have your
daughter will you set up like you know
it's dinner time and do it at the table
or will you rock it in front of the tv
with my daughter at the table solo in
front of the tv
nice nothing's better than that what's
your favorite thing to cook for yourself
oh man i i don't know i'm my crab cake i
like the
i like to grill but if i'm gonna cook
the crab cake i make is probably the
best thing to make for myself but i also
like i go to the
seafood market and i just grab shrimp
and i'll take them home and steam them
up real quick it takes five minutes
throw some old bounds some shrimp
steam them up they're great little beers
you grill for yourself
yeah i love the i'm just saying when you
say cook i grill more than i cook
you know i'm not a i'm not i don't bake
i'm not a desserts guy
but uh see sickler and they're making a
bundt cake italian
i'll bake some pasta i like to take um
fra diavolo spicy sauce put it in a
little bacon
dish and then cover it with some italian
seasonings and mozzarella and shrimp
and make shrimp fried diablo like that
oh that's fine
yeah i think this guy's all [ __ ]
classy now me too that's [ __ ] two big
points right there
oh man if you have enough
self-confidence to [ __ ] grill for
yourself that's [ __ ] that's a man
right there
i'll tell you that that's all right i
got one uh wait this is
sorry what was that i was saying it's
easier i just think it's easier to throw
something on a fire and cook it real
quick
yeah no i got you um i would just order
chinese and sit there like a big pig and
watch [ __ ]
offenses
[Laughter]
fully well if you're growing in your one
bedroom apartment in queens i think
there's
i think there's issues um what kind of
jarred
tomato sauce will you buy and we'll
order tomato
that's a yes i will um and i really
really really love
rayo's um what you got rails money
holy [ __ ] this guy's rich they're the
they're the one i'll go for and if you
look at their
green door and it's it's they're the
best i mean that's
they've taken the stigma out of [ __ ]
ragu
and all yeah that's the cadillac dude
that's the cattle
nothing's better than that i've always
my mom would never have bought rails
because it's [ __ ] like ten dollars a
bottle
and i get i get pushback for my girl
when we go into the grocery store
if i try to spend a little money on
[ __ ] pasta sauce
but rayo's i always had a stigma with
because i knew that they were [ __ ]
over
charging us from the jump they are i
mean that's like 10
15 bucks and you start getting in the
[ __ ] vodka sauce
you got to write a check it's like what
the [ __ ]
gotta start moving some things around
you get a picky eater as a child
right she loves this spaghetti but i've
convinced her her mom and i have
convinced her that this one
rayo sauce is the sauce at the
restaurant
so that's the only [ __ ] sauce you'll
eat but i'm already with it because it's
two of us going at it you know what yeah
and i don't do i don't do pasta that
much that attend
a nine dollar bottle of sauce is it's
all right i make that [ __ ] stretch you
know i'm saying i'm using it in pasta
and in the shrimp i'm making it straight
this guy's versatile i've not forgotten
my garbage roots
you're all classed nowadays do you put a
little bit of water in
the in the jar and shake it up to get
the last little bit
i don't really got a scrap rubber
no i got a rubber scraper those rubber
scrapers and they still get everything
out
this guy's [ __ ] classy i know man
oh [ __ ] right dude rails nobody's ever
responded with rails
yeah rails off the [ __ ] jumper you
got your act together
what grocery store do you shop at now
ralph's just
mostly ralph's okay all right i'm loyal
to the
store that's closest to me to be honest
you know what i mean yeah
yeah and ralph's is right up the middle
okay how do you feel about the
rotisserie chicken at the supermarket
were you dabbling a rotisserie chicken
you like a roto
i like a roto but i've [ __ ] with it
only a few times
from the market yeah it's it's good to
and plus if i'm being honest i'm wasting
most of it because i just like the
breast meat
yeah me too nothing but dude they're
like 4.99 you get a perfectly cooked
bird
i'm a skin guy i like this skin real
thin
i like to slice it real thin and then
make little i love sandwiches
too oh come on you're talking to two
sandwich guys over here right
well you put some chips on that sandwich
you would chip on the sandwich guy
i am i'm fries on the burger chips and
pretzels on the side i like that crunch
chips and pretzels or or
i don't mean to get holy [ __ ] pretzels
on a sandwich oh yeah dude i do turkey
and cheese with a little bit of hers
pretzels on there
good [ __ ] night i know what i'm doing
tonight exactly it turkey and cheese or
ham and cheese with some pretzels on top
it's fantastic
it ain't nothing better it's a little
it's like panko breading you know what i
mean a little bit of zest for you
get it good crunch a little salt
delicious it's the salt that does it man
i love it all right i got one now i
assume
a gentleman such as yourself would not
partake in any kind of business such as
this
but i have to ask the questions so if i
offend i apologize
but when was the last time or have you
ever paid with anything with a money
order
yeah um it's been a minute but when i
feel like when i first moved to
california when i got an apartment they
made you get a money order back then
all right yeah that's okay [ __ ] like
that but i've never paid for
something outside of like uh some sort
of registration or
application for with a money order all
right you're not dropping the rent off
or the mortgage off in a [ __ ] money
order from 7-eleven
yeah me either shout out to my landlord
it's just just a follow-up to that
uh i think this is garbage i think kevin
disagrees with me
but are you a cash back guy will you get
cash back
when you make a purchase what do you
what you mean actually at the register
yeah only if i need it
i try not to use cash as much these days
because i'm just using my card for
points and [ __ ] for travel and all
that crap so i
try not to dick with cash but these days
with that corona virus i've been doing
things like haircuts and you know
people like to work a little bit of cash
these days yeah cash is king
cash i feel like i'm in the 20s again
you know what i mean whacking everybody
off with a couple of fragiles and keep
it moving cash and gold baby
[Laughter]
i like that all right pretty [ __ ]
classy you might sickly
yeah dude this guy's [ __ ] bulletproof
now you might you
you're like you you say you grill a lot
this is we're not grilled guys i was
trying i went we rented i rented a house
a couple of weeks ago up
upstate and i was i was the grill guy
and i don't know what i'm doing
what's the classiest kind of grill is it
charcoal or propane
now what do you got what's what's the
way in here
if you're if you're a purist then
charcoal is definitely the way to go but
i i live in an apartment here in la i
can't have a charcoal grill so it's got
to be propane but there's
nothing like just the smell
and the taste of something that comes
off those hot coals
all right man it's [ __ ] a-okay i
would say that's more garbage that
propane is classier because when i think
of charcoal
i think of the couple of times that we
went out to like some kind of function
at a public park
and you know they have like the already
made grills at public park sometimes
i always look the people that were
grilling out there with charcoal like
they were [ __ ] trash
well two things they are trash
but they're trash that doesn't have a
grill yes exactly
you know what i'm saying they're doing
what they can but propane
you know it's just that's it's cheating
i guess you if you're gonna get those
cold
you gotta heat them up right you gotta
get them nice and white also
charcoal plus most people treat it like
trash they spray a gallon of [ __ ]
lighter fuel
[ __ ] and then blast that [ __ ]
you know it's fun
that's fun for trash fireworks and
things like
trash are big in the fireworks are you
are you into fireworks
i like fireworks
i like fireworks my brother in delaware
gets like the legit ones and they'll
fire three or four of those
[ __ ] off and it's just like
it's insane yeah you should add to your
questions i don't know maybe you have
this but for trash people any fireworks
injuries you should add that to your
list of things oh yeah
we've we've touched on that i almost
lost an eye to a black cat when i was
like seven
yeah i caught some shrapnel
it was that the oldest trick in the book
oh i lit it the fuse went out
all of a sudden the fuse is back on and
my buddy johnny's holding he gets a hot
potato at that point
and i was the loser what was it this
year i know it was the pandemic but
did they loosen up the laws on fireworks
because i feel like every night in new
york
it was like [ __ ] it was like the bay
of pigs yeah it was bad dude it was
it has it still hasn't stopped it's been
it was
every night for the and i mean we were
talking about
cannons like oh yeah dude it was like
d-day in my neighborhood
every [ __ ] night i was waking up at
four in the morning like we were
thinking mortar [ __ ] saving private
foley over here
yeah holy [ __ ] all right we just got a
couple more questions we're going to get
you out of here this has been absolutely
fantastic
kippy what do you got dude do you have
any pets now
yes um
it's with my daughter's mom and my
daughter over there is the cat who i
i've never been a cat guy but this
[ __ ] cat i love this [ __ ] cat this
cat's like every woman in my life
sees me runs over cuddles me cuddle
wants me to pet pat pat and then after a
while just turns on me
bites the [ __ ] out of me calls me makes
me bleed and then and it comes back five
minutes later
yeah i can't [ __ ] with them but people
that say that
it's always a guy it's always somebody
i'm not a cat guy but they get one that
they they end up liking
got me she got me and plus she's
internet famous when my stepson was like
god i don't know seven or eight um the
cat was laying up on this little balcony
like this little walkway area where his
mom lives and he rode his bike by and
put his hand up and
give her a high five and she straight up
high-fived him and that cat's got more
views
i think i've seen that that's my son
at high five i'll never i'll do that
damn he knows famous cats too
this guy's checking all the boxes and
his family
won't wait bro you don't pull weight in
this family yeah
from an early age yeah yeah yeah body's
got a full airway
[ __ ] wide receivers and cool cat
tricks i like it
i always thought it was trashy though
remember when you were a kid and then on
the news at the end they would show like
the squirrel that could surf
he'd be like [ __ ] dude i've met that
squirrel that water skis at a boat show
an ac
and dude peanuts knows his way around a
[ __ ] above ground pool
he was all coked up at the keto table
they were feeding them ketamine but he
[ __ ] he knew what he was he was doing
the one hand the wave
yeah all right kippy what do you got
all right this is i i saw this this is a
baltimore thing
this is bananas to me do you do
sauerkraut at thanksgiving
i don't know what okay that's a
baltimore thing though right
did you know that i i i to answer your
question i don't know i grew up in
italian family so
yeah all traditional easter was ham
thanksgiving was turkey but we had
lasagna stuffed shells big ziti
all that so we never had some [ __ ]
sauerkraut wrong somebody was smacked
your grandma would have slapped the [ __ ]
out of you yeah i can't believe you
asked that
question she would have spit on
that question did not come from me i
just want that on the record right now
sour but i'll tell you a southern thing
that we like is french fries with gravy
like brown gravy come on yeah i think
that's a fat guy thing
i [ __ ] love it too that's fantastic
throw a little cheese on there good
night
um kippy you got anything else
ah let's see here i think i got one more
for ya
anyone in your family ever owned like a
trick remote control car
like one that hit like a top speed that
you had to fix and you know you jumped
it off like a
[ __ ] baseball field or something i'll
tell you not the rc
cars but we had um
a quasi uncle i guess he wasn't really
an uncle but then
which is always trashy but they're the
best they're sometimes awesome dudes
forget about it he was in the rc planes
he was into the plane
so he got us into a plane briefly
briefly
that's not too bad i had a helicopter
that never made it off the ground the
one time oh yeah i lost a drone a few
weeks ago with my nephew that thing took
off i was
in some that's it for high drone
come on i'll get you a bb gun [ __ ] that
oh that's it for me ma'am that's it i
gotta say let me ask you this because uh
about
a a past guest on the show a couple
weeks ago stunned us
with something uh comedian shane torres
asked us the question so i'm gonna pass
that question on to you yeah
just to close out now you're all class
in my book
but what would you say is the classiest
thing that you
do does anything stick out in your mind
that you try to make a point to do
or you know something that you're like
i'm treating myself with this type thing
i i'm being a dad um
you know my dad was a great but i only
got him
for a short amount of time so i'm trying
to do what i can to make sure my ass
sticks around
so i can be you know here and and
you know enjoy uh my kids [ __ ] aces
oh
jesus christ what a [ __ ] answer
if i get married will you be my best man
yeah right i just want to hear this
speech
[ __ ] not a dry eye in the house when
sickler gets done
that was that was a [ __ ] key and he
knows cpr for when you croak
that's [ __ ] smart you got a better
chance of living than dying with me
though yeah dude
this guy's putting on solid [ __ ] dude
first of all he's a gem of a [ __ ] guy
sat through all the tech issues we had
figures it out does it on the fly
saves lives damn grill i mean this guy's
[ __ ]
yeah man flawless in my book 100 class
ladies and gentlemen mr ryan sickler
thank
[Applause]
thank you for the crowd work too of
course brother now is anything you want
the folks out there to know before you
let you get out of here
just make sure uh you subscribe to my
podcast the honeydew go over to
uh ryan sickler.com the
honeydewpodcast.com
follow me on social media ryan sickler
it's all there
and um yeah that's it buddy thank you so
much
what do you got for him yeah guys same
thing just make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
uh full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well and if you
want a gas digital
uh subscription use promo code ayg get a
free trial get all the bonus the live
streams the chat
you get the episodes before they come
out and plus we get to wet our beaks a
little bit you know what i mean a couple
of bucks in kippy and foley's pockets
yeah a little bit of cash you know what
i'm saying yeah gang thank you so much
mr sickler thank you again buddy all
class i'll tell you that right now
thank you both seriously i really
appreciate you having me sorry about all
that tech stuff at the top
thank you so much guys we will see you
next week peace